[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner trocken
wird heute gibt es eine ganz besondere
aufgabe zum ersten advent ich habe eine
schnelle bestellung bekommen und sag ich
jetzt mal mehr netto umgestellt hat halo
spiel dar alt und reichste stadt wenn
ich habe für extra gedicht schöne ja
dieses mal vor die erste kerze leuchtet
auf advent advent mein blutkreislauf der
eiert rum und ich muss dann seewege dem
brennende ziele in meinem rand die
mutter sagt willsch mit mir backe du
kennst schon mal die andere mandeln
hacke 30 moment mein einwand war
begründet ich glaube mein handeln ziehen
entzünden und anne pamperin kuchen traum
mache ich mit links zum purzelbaum
dekore fliege auf bode um noch bleibt
die mutter ziemlich stunden die flasche
rum letzten schlager á la la la dann ist
mir fehlen die spüle gefallen
der fertige transceiver ja jetzt
komplett vergessen
so bleibt der mutter dann doch trage ich
brauche lösung ohne frage und ich hab
nämlich dann bestellt heimlich bestellt
tannebaum trotz von felice papa will
schöne weihnachten wünschen und was
steht guten rutsch ich liebe euch alle
danke dir halt für deine bestellung und
besonders schöne bestellung mit dem sex
gedicht kann ich natürlich nicht neues
sage also werde ich euch jetzt einmal
zeigen wie ich den tannenbaum macht für
diejenige den rest kennen ich mir nichts
wenn ich das hier schon mal der torten
welt und hier zeige ich euch rezepte
tipps und tricks die ihr nachmachen
könnt ihr könnt es alles nachlesen auch
dieses rezept heute auf www.starbett.de
und jetzt eigentlich einfach mal wie ich
den tannenbaum für der harald und seine
mutter brothers und jetzt kommen wir zum
rezept und zwar ein bisschen mehr als
den hefeteig stellen und dafür braucht
die folgen der zutaten
ihr braucht 500 gramm mehl 80 gramm
zucker 250 milliliter milch die es jetzt
schon schön glaube 80 g weiche butter 1
ei einen teelöffel salz und einen
gefüllt frische hilfe und damit der teig
später schneller auf geht müsst ihr
jetzt erstmal die hefe aktivieren das
heißt wir werden jetzt mit der milch
auflösen und dann etwas zucker mit dazu
geben so beschleunigen wir später eben
diesen gern princess zuerst nämlich hier
die hefe heraus und brücke ist sie ihnen
die milch und dann verliere ich das
ganze doch nicht wichtigen lieferschein
auflösen kann
und jetzt kommt hier noch etwas zucker
mit rein und zum verhilft einfach damit
die hilfe ist schneller aufgeht und das
ganze werde ich jetzt mit einem
küchentuch abdecken und werden an einen
warmen ort stellen
und ich mache es immer so dass ich meine
im ofen auf 50 grad vorheizen
macht ihnen dann aus dass auf 40 grad
abkühlt und da gebe ich dann eben diese
mischung mit rein damit sie etwas sehen
kann
und so sieht das ganze aus wenn es 15
minuten im ofen war ich störe das mal
kurz zur seite und jetzt nehme ich mir
einfach meine ruhe schüssel in den teig
verkneten möchte gibt da mein mädel
hinein
dann gebe ich doch gleich diese hilfe
mischung ein
und wenn ihr verhindern wollte ist es
euch ausläuft dann kann es auch in
dieser großen schüssel aufgehen lassen
da kommt jetzt auch das sei es mit dazu
dass ein und auch die weiche butter und
dann auch noch den restlichen zucker und
dann muss ich den teig bei niedriger
stufe in meiner kitchenaid verkneten ihr
könnt natürlich auch eine andere
küchenmaschine nehmen und wer gar keine
küchenmaschine hat kann auch mit den
händen den teig verkneten
[Musik]
und dann sollte der teig richtig schön
weich sein aber nicht mehr an den
fingern kleben und dann nehmt ihr euch
den teig einfach nur tykwer ausschüsse
also gebt ihr etwas mehl auf eine
arbeitsfläche und dann vom tier daraus
eine kugel in dem ihr den teig von außen
nach innen in die mitte geht dann können
das ganze umdrehen und zu einer kugel
formen dann kommt etwas medien eure
schüssel dann kommt der tag hinein und
wird mit etwas mehl bedeckt und dann mit
einem tuch abgedeckt und dann gebt ihr
den teig wieder alle entfernt also bei
mir wieder in den ofen und dann bleibt
er jetzt für etwa eine halbe stunde
da geht jetzt relativ schnell auf weil
wir ja die hefe bauherr aktiviert haben
auf jeden fall müsst ihr ihn so lange
gehen lassen will ist es sich einfach
verdient hat und in der zwischenzeit
können wir jetzt schon mal die nuss
bildung und der zirkus vorbereiten und
dafür zeige ich euch jetzt einmal mit
halten für die nuss füllung braucht ihr
200 gramm nüsse ich habe jetzt hier
frisch geriebene haselnüsse ihr braucht
ein 1 2 esslöffel cacau daneben biete
richtigen charakterkopf und kein cover
drei esslöffel zucker enthaltene
esslöffel zimt und etwa eine halbe tasse
milch jetzt gebt ihr einfach alles in
eine kleine schüssel und verrührt ist
schön miteinander
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt hier nur so viel milch
mit 1 ist das ganze eine feuchte masse
ist die darf aber nicht zu nass werden
deswegen gibt er lieber nach und nach
mehr station
und so ist das ganze richtig perfekt die
nuss füllung ständig kurz zur seite und
bei den deshalb schon mal den zuckerguss
vorbereiten ich habe jetzt hier 100
gramm puderzucker und werde jetzt hier
etwas zitronensaft dazugeben und zwar so
etwa drei esslöffel und dann verliere
ich das schön miteinander
[Musik]
ein teil dieses richtig schön
aufgegangen und jetzt zeige ich euch wie
immer ganz einfach diese tarnung warum
hinbekommt und dazu gebe ich jetzt
einfach etwas mehl auf eine
arbeitsfläche
das publikum hatte weil es da nicht
drauf kleben bleibt und ich gebe da
meinen tag drauf geht aber auch ganz gut
auf einer dauert war folie oder einfach
auf einer gut wenn wir hinten
arbeitsfläche dann rolle ich mir den
teig aus und zwar so etwa 30 cm breit
werden und damit es schön rechteckig
bleiben können sagt immer mal wieder
anheben und in die richtige form sehen
und zwar müsst ihr das viereck so leicht
versetzt machen so dass es eben haberl
programm ist das eben die zwei seiten
parallel sind und die hier sind auch
wahre dann können wir das ganze mal
ausprobieren
ich möchte nämlich jetzt zwei dreiecke
ausschneiden und das passt so und weil
ich aus silikon mathe nicht schneiden
kann oder nicht möchte dann ist ja nicht
kaputtgeht mache ich das einfach mit
meinem linearen aber es könnte auch mit
einem stumpfen gegenstand also zum
beispiel auch eine palette oder und
nehmen ihr direkt meine war folie auf
der ich das dann auch später backen
möchte und da gebe ich
mein erstes dreieck drauf dann nehmt ihr
euch einfach eure muss füllungen und
streift die darauf
[Musik]
und da legt ihr dann euer zweites
dreieck drauf und zieht es richtig schön
in form damit hier alles bedeckt wird
und jetzt wird der tannenbaum schön
geformt und zwar wird er jetzt hier
seitlich eingeschnitten und damit das
ganze schön regelmäßig wie lege ich mir
da in die mitte so eine palette und dann
schneide ich hier wieder mit dem
linearen weil ich jetzt kein messer
nehmen will einfach hier
die seiten in etwa 2 cm ab stunden ein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und jetzt wird der tannenbaum noch
geformt und zwar nehmt ihr euch jetzt
die zwei spitzen und tricks er einmal
nach oben und legt sie wieder hin
im zweiten genauso einmal nach oben
nehmen und umdrehen jetzt bei dem
vierten kann ich es ja auch schon zwei
mal drehen und jetzt immer zwei mal
drehen oder ebenso offen
und das letzte hier werde jetzt nichts
wirbeln besonderen wetter rechts und
links wegschneiden dann wird dieser
strom noch einmal halbiert und das wäre
ich das einfach da unten hin so als
kleinen baumstamm und jetzt kann ich die
folie so wie sie ist ein kompakter
stehen und das ganze dass ich jetzt noch
mal im oben gehen so etwa 20 minuten und
je zwei leichen an die oberfläche mit
ganz wenig eigelb und milch bestreichen
damit da einfach schön glänzt und jetzt
werde ich ihnen bei 190 grad in etwa 20
bis 25 minuten backen bis die oberfläche
leicht braun wird und wenn der baum dann
gebacken ist neben den aus dem ofen
damit sie da etwas so aus und dann
streicht ihr da diesen zuckerguss drauf
einfach ganz dünn so sieht dann der
fertige baum aus ich hoffe dieses rezept
gefällt euch nachlesen könnt ihr es auch
www.starbett.de da gibt's auch die
rubrik über mich meinen job und meinen
blog und natürlich auch meine
facebook-seite und falls euch dieses
konzept gefällt und teilt gerne mein
video gibt in der bewertung oder einen
kommentar dann freue ich mich sehr
darüber und jetzt wünsche ich euch noch
einen schönen ersten advent euch und
euren familien 100 sehen wir uns schon
nächste woche wenn ihr wollt oder gerne
etwas früher auf meinen youtube channel
und ich wünsche euch alles gute bis
dahin bis dahin tschüss
liga nicht
[Musik]